[Music]
foreign
sir thank you for coming
thank you for uh for me
of course of course you're in boston now
right
yeah okay wow okay so uh i mean
we're doing this 20-minute leader show
and
you know we've been i've been following
you for quite some time and it looks
like you're doing such cool things at
flint capital that i can't wait to learn
a little bit more can you tell me a
little bit
a little bit more about yourself what is
flint capital
and what do you do as a venture capital
sure uh so fertile talk a little bit
about myself
my original background is actually
technical uh my first degree is computer
science
and i also lived i moved between
countries so i was born
raised in russia when i moved to israel
lived for many years in israel
when i was uh well all over the place i
went to university
but at some point i lived in television
so between like television
basically i was kind of lucky
right out of university actually when i
was still studying university i
uh joined company called competion as in
play number one
competition is one of the success
stories of israeli incubator you can
even find this story and start a nation
book
and when i think about being employee
number one you can do
a lot of different stuff so i was doing
software development where
when we needed to open an office in the
states
like all uh all founders had families i
didn't so i was you want to go
so i moved to uh to boston around like
more than 20 years ago uh done bunch of
stuff i
i was with competition for more than
nine years i've done
all kind of different stuff there left
after the ipo a couple of years after
the ipo
been part of a bunch of different
startups on the technical side then kind
of switch to a dark side went to mit did
business degree
uh started to do some angel investments
yeah uh and i joined flint about five
years ago
as partner here in boston
uh so flint we we early stage fund
we do see the rounds
we a little bit different from most of
the venture funds in a sense what we run
completely distributed shops so we're
three partners
uh i'm in boston a number one in
california third one in europe
uh we also have office in israel and we
have principles in israel so we have
we have many offices we don't have a
single office of more than two people in
it
and one of the reasons behind
this structure is what we feel uh what
we can bring a lot of added value
to the companies from israel and europe
uh when we come to yes we've
helped here on the ground with help of
raising the next
financing grounds etc when a second fund
now
we uh if you look at our portfolio i
would say
it's about fifty percent israel
water europe quarter years plus or minus
we don't have specific location but it
just
happens and we do both b2b and b2c
we fairly brought we have
digital health cyber fintech voice tech
devops if you look it's like
probably the common denominator between
all these companies we have a lot of ai
in their products
i don't like to say we invest in i
because i think ai is technology we
invest in products
and right now any product you build
it have to have some kind of ai company
so sergey i'd love to hear your input
what does it mean to invest in
to invest in a product rather than a
technology because
uh you know i mean i'm also i'm sitting
with with j ventures now
and and it's pretty common now to see in
every slide deck we use ai2
and then fill in the blank and that's
just almost a given
what do you mean invest in a product and
not in the technology
so uh first we'll look we look at what
uh
what is your product what problem it
solves right if there is a problem in
the market and you're solving this
problem
in way better way when anything out
there when it's a good product
if the market is big you know it's it's
it's
a usual thing like you look at market
you look at your product you look at
competitive landscape
and ai is just uh in our way to build
uh your competitive advantage basically
you
especially when you have some unique
data which you can build your eye on
what helps but it's it doesn't mean you
have to have ai
from one side and from another side
having ai doesn't mean you're building
the right product this uh you can build
very very
interesting ai system which wouldn't
have any product market fit so what's
your point of investing
no but i mean you know even in the in
the context of ai
you know you can go as and start
something as simple as
you know just a simple a logistic regret
model
or you could go as far as doing you know
all these really complicated
convolution convolutional neural
networks
where and and there's no and it seems
like there's no differentiation today in
terms of
how people how people um showcase
their ai capabilities right they will
both say
how is an investor and a technical
investor how do you
how much do you care about the type of
technology that they're using within
this realm of ai
yeah we care a lot actually because
what's what's your competitive advantage
if you're doing
something which is like everybody is
doing when and you don't have any
proprietary data then
probably you're not going to have that
much of a competitive advantage
i mean uh my background is technical so
when i
talk to founders i usually tell them you
can be as technical as you want with me
i can understand i can still write a
code if i really want to
uh and uh we when when we do the
diligence we usually
bring in a lot of uh experts i mean we
have
we have a bunch of companies in our
portfolio a lot of them use ai nowadays
uh at least several of these companies
are kind of leaders in their segments so
we have access to very very smart people
which one much smarter than me who can
get
and actually ask very very pointed
questions so
usually when we when we do diligence
on the new company we usually would ask
like ctos of our
portfolio companies or some other people
in the field who
really understand this very very deeply
and if you tell us what this is really
something
interesting this is really some
proprietary ai
some proprietary data people are
building it differently when when our
people are doing it
yeah that's that's an interesting
proposition from an outside if it's just
a novel like
we we use ai because everybody use ai
when
it's so you know in times of now corona
when everybody
all of it all every almost every company
has to deal with this changing
and evolving world of moving to
distributed teams
and you know i'm also i'm a software
engineer at hippo and overnight
we had to essentially start working
remotely
with 250 people and i had the chance to
do the onboarding
uh with a company and all of a sudden
you know they explained to me that on
the first day you come and you get these
shirts and you have a big
and they had to give me that over over
zoom and they did it wonderfully but
it nevertheless was a different
experience in it it requires every
company to make adjustments
so your structure is already distributed
so it might you might feel it a little
bit less but what's happening in the vc
world
all together and then i'd love to hear
about flint capital specifically
uh so we say
it's uh in terms of working
i know a lot of funds are still working
pretty much uh
vc's usually venture fund doesn't have
way
many people so it's much easier to go
remote for them
for us it's natural because we're kind
of remote first
and on top of that i personally i worked
with remote teams pretty much all my
working career
i i was managing teams in israel when i
was working from boston
i was managing some outsourcing teams
who i worked with
so i i know how to do it i what i found
useful what
if you build company what's called
remote first what from a day
zero and you have now more and more
companies who build that way from a day
zero you have remote teams it's much
easier to do it
when if you would have a company which
usually
gets developers and then suddenly you
need to go remote because
you have you built all your processes
from the beginning basically you need
uh the difference between like working
completely remotely and working from
your offices
there's a lot of communication which
goes on when you're working in the same
space
and this communication is not kind of
scheduling communications basically
could your talk or somebody
have a question they just come by to
your office and quickly ask questions
you lose this communication when you go
remote so what you need to do
if you want to do it correctly you need
to make sure you have
way more scheduled communication than
usually you do
like if you usually have one status
meeting
in office a week do two free status
meetings
uh maybe shorter but do more of them
because you
you need to compensate for this
communication
and you need you need to know how to
manage people remotely and all this
stuff but
i think it's a huge advantage actually
and i do expect what
people after the corona times you will
see more and more and more teams we have
we actually invested in one company
which is completely remote first where
john uh one of our portfolio companies
way from
beginning we never had an office it's
like two founders who are in
amsterdam and all the team is completely
distributed we don't have a single
office the team is completely
distributed
and they get a lot of advantages because
of that because we can hire a person
anywhere in the world and it's very cost
effective we can get for
the best talent they can find things
like that
i mean sorry i mean it makes a lot of
sense that you know github i think is
distributed from day one
and you you have this insurgence of
companies
how do you how do big companies uh deal
with it
that when they don't necessarily have
the cloud infrastructure to do this
transition
or they don't have the processes to go
and handle this
sort of collaborative nature of online
because
i mean a lot of tech companies from the
90s still are still around
and they don't have all they don't even
have a lot of these things in the cloud
right
a lot of these are on enterprise
computers that are in the office
well so one uh you have technology
which allows you to work with
all these computers not on the cloud too
so you have all kind of vpns
actually we just invested in a company
well i guess by the time
uh webcast will go live it will be
unknown so i can talk about it we have
uh we just invested
a week ago we closed the deal company
called sayola
it's an israeli cyber security company
early stage
we led around and they allow you to
access
your services your applications
from anywhere it doesn't matter you in
the cloud or you
uh your application in the cloud on
servers it doesn't matter if you're in
local network or you're somewhere
remotely
you can access this service without vpn
without uh
complication it's very easy way very
secure way
so you you have tools like that
which you can use to uh to access system
obviously when you have a big company
which is working certain way
it's a challenge uh the more agile
environment allows you to do it much
much easier
but i think by now
uh at least in high tech uh i think even
the biggest and oldest companies in high
tech we still
already working with some remote teams
so we have some kind of infrastructure
in place
it's still a challenge but i think it's
more
organizational challenge than technology
challenge because
technology is there you can go remote uh
today very easily so you you closed the
deal last week
are you are you still actively looking
for deals in general all over
the same way that you looked at them
before or are you now much more focused
on
things that would make sense in this new
light of
of the working environment because of
corona it's actually
funny uh we're working the same way we
worked before
it's actually funny because
uh in in
in like last months and the next month
we're gonna close several deals
uh more deals when we closed in the last
cafe
it's not because it's on a purpose it
just happens when we see a good company
and we like it and we want to invest
we're investing
so we just closed
two deals within last couple weeks and
there are
a couple deals in the works one term
ship is signed
another one is uh temperatured out
so we we actually
probably in in the in this month we
probably will be even more active in
terms of like deal number
uh but i think in general for us it
doesn't really matter i don't think
we're working the same we worked before
and
we if we see good companies we're going
to invest
i i think in general we will see slow
down if
you want kind of my feeling what will
happens
in vc vault yeah you will see some slow
down because a lot of funds
probably will kind of take
let's sit it out a little bit approach
and see what's going on
too much uncertainty things are moving
too fast
and you don't understand what's going on
i think
uh i i would guess what in the next
couple months a lot of funds will
kind of wait and see uh then we'll start
investing but
i think the price of investments in vc
vault will slow down
because one of the problems we're
probably gonna have
which is more long term kind of problem
is
i would expect within the next year or
two years
will have way less money going into
venture funds just from lp site
uh for different reasons not really
related to vc
but uh like think about
let's say you have a family office which
have 100 million dollars
to invest and uvc allocation is 5
which means 5 million dollars and your
stock market allocation is like 70
of this problem that's kind of in a
ballpark
now think about your 70 percent now
shrink to about
50 million yeah so you your vc
allocation suddenly become
became from five percent like seven
percent or eight percent
what it means uh what for the next year
until it gets
to the five percent you're probably not
going to put any money into vc
right and what's going to happen in a
lot of institutional
peace our institutional piece will take
less risky approach also
if i would have to guess
stock market probably going to get
better returns
in like next three or five years just
because it's kind of crashed
yeah so when you kind of compare returns
in stock market and we see world
if stock market is getting better
returns you probably put more money into
the stock market so because of all these
issues
i would expect to see less money going
from institutional side into venture
funds
which means on a venture fund side it
takes you longer to raise your next
round
you kind of expect what instead of like
usual cycle raising the next fund in two
to three years
it may takes a lot uh take a lot of
funds longer time
to raise the next one so it means what
we can't fund we're gonna
probably drag a little bit to make sure
we have
money to invest right instead of like in
two years
we we're gonna drag the same money for
like three years four years
makes sense so i would guess what you
will see a little bit of
kind of uh slowing down
it's hard to say if it's going to be
like 50
drop or 30 drop a 20 drop but
i would expect to see some of that at
least no no it's fascinating you know i
mean i
i i'm at stanford now and i remember
when i when i was
trying to decide whether to go and
pursue an academic degree in computer
science or to build my own company
one of the things that i kept hearing
was this is the best time to build a
company
you know there's a pro there's more
there's so many
interested vc's there's not enough
entrepreneurs that are working on many
on really meaningful problems
one of the things i'm interested in is
working on some large-scale
products for for developing areas and
but and you know all of a sudden uh you
know
eight months into my degree and corona
breaks out so so i feel like i won a
little bit
uh but uh well uh on the good
side if you think about it i i think the
good companies are still gonna get
uh enough of the venture uh capital
attention
if you think about it the best uh
2008 was a great year for starting
company
if you can get your uh
[Music]
i saw this a couple times why is that
because uh think about this way
if you if the economy isn't down and
you're just starting your company
you're gonna you're gonna ride the whole
wave
of the economy going up so if you start
a company in 2008
you get to a scale-up part somewhere
around 2009 2010.
you you all you build your company you
you starting you you testing your ideas
and in 2009 by the time the economy
started to go up
your company is ready to scale so you
you get this wave from the very
beginning
and you ride it all to the top and you
have time to exit
until the wave is done so that's kind of
the best way to build your company
now it's harder to get investment in
2008 so it's harder to
raise money but if you're building
something really unique and something
interesting
it's your best time so it will be
harder to start company if it's
something like
like in the middle like if you're trying
to build company which is gonna be sell
sold for less 100 million dollars it's
probably gonna
harder to do it yeah but to build a
really big company to build really
interesting
bread kind of breakfast company
it's about time because you're gonna
ride the whole wave
so it's so the funnel is the funnel is
is narrower so it's it's harder to get
started but those that do get started
they have the economic advantage of of
being on the
on the up-and-coming economics yeah well
again
you need to find uh you need to find
this product market feedback
by the time everything goes up
because if but if every time everything
goes up you have this product market fit
you just scale it
and uh writing tight
right helpful holy so
definitely definitely definitely sergei
before we
before we leave uh i need three words
that describe you
wow oh yeah
well i guess uh curious and founders
friendly i know
i love it okay so i'm gonna say curious
founder friendly and then curious and
then founder friendly
so i'll do both google combinations
sergey thank you very very much
thank you healthy
yeah you too